and I want to hey I want to tell Shaq I
asked you specifically this evening
because he felt that I was a shame in
you or ignoring you and that would never
be the case and uh you showed him what
what you were all about the way you
crushed all the centers
in the league for a couple of years
there so uh I'm on your side Shaq don't
ever let anybody tell you anything
different and listen you're not speaking
to me was the best thing that happened
to my career because all I wanted to do
was impress you so so I will talk to you
soon inshallah and I love you very much
and I will never ever have beef with the
great Kareem Abdul-Jabbar you ain't got
to worry about that that's back at you I
love you too and uh I wanted you guys to
keep on impressing the whole world with
our game it's a wonderful game yep I'll
talk to you soon cap thank you Captain
yeah take care
that was I wasn't expecting that at the
end
that was very special
I'm not a sensitive guy but he would
never look at me but never talk to me so
I thought he didn't like me but I'm the
type I don't get sensitive I'm gonna go
okay you're not gonna talk to me watch
this so it just
and then you know my mother and father
would say when people criticize you see
if there's some truth and then criticism
Shaq's one of the greatest Lakers ever
and then Kareem said well if he's so
great how come they keep getting to up
in the playoffs you can't respond to
that motivation not from camp
you know what I'm saying John contact
can't say that nobody else but so so
like you write it so like I use it as
just motivation then about four years
ago he pulled me to the side and said
man you read an article you said I don't
like it that's not true I love it and
like he gave me a big hug but
and ever since then we've been very
close but I'm uh happy for LeBron I'm
happy for the Lakers organization and
I never thought that record would be
broken but that was gonna be broken but
now it definitely ain't gonna be broken
shot Candice talking about he's trying
to play another five years man it ain't
going nowhere that thing gonna be about
48 000 points ain't it
LeBron is just the eighth player in the
history of the NBA to be the all-time
scoring leader the question now how far
will he take it James Harden weighing in
one of one congrats Pro Chef Curry
congrats King James Legendary Legendary
stuff right there with the amount of
points and swish 41 unbelievable
congrats that's very